اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في اخبار الساعه من
العربيه نستعرض معكم ابرز المستجدات وفي
العناوين
ازمه السودان على اجوده اجتماع استثنائي
لوزراء الخارجيه العرب في القاهره يبحث
ايضا عوده سوريا للجامعه
تزامنا مع ملاحظات جده لتثبيت الهدنه في
السودان تجدد الاشتباكات في خرطوم وتحليق
مكثف للمقاتلات
خيارات متزامنه في القرم وانذارات جويه في
كييف وتحضيرات من مخاطر على محطه
الزابوريج النوويه
قبل اسبوع من انتخابات الرئاسه التركيه
اسطنبول تتحول لساحه استعراض للحشود بين
اردوغان وخصمه
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا نبدا ساعتين اخباريه من
اجتماع استثنائي في القاهره يعقده وزراء
خارجيه جامعه الدول العربيه الاجتماع الذي
يبدا بعد قليل يبحثوا ازمه السودان
وتطورات المشهد المتصاعد في الحرب الدائره
بين قوات الجيش والدعم السريع لبناء موقف
عربي موحد حيال الازمه السودانيه كما يبحث
الوزراء مسوده قرار لاعاده مشاركه وفود
سوريا في الاجتماعات الخاصه بها في ضوء
نتائج الاجتماعات الوزاريه العربيه
المصغره التي عقدت في السعوديه والاردن
لبحث عوده سوريا الى الجامعه العربيه
ودعوتها للقمه العربيه المقبله في الرياض
اجتماع اليوم مشاهدينا الذي ينعقد بمقر
الامانه العامه للجامعه العربيه في
القاهره سبقه امس لقاء المندوبين الدائمين
للدول الاعضاء بالجامعه العربيه وشهد تا
ايدا واسعا لعوده سوريا الى مقعدها
بالجامعه واشارت مصادر الى ان اعضاء جامعه
الدول العربيه سيصوتون على الغاء تجميل
عضويه سوريا
هذا ونشرت مجله المجله مسوده قرار
بالجامعه العربيه تعيد مشاركته
وفي المنظمات التابعه لها نتابع
[موسيقى]
ومن القهر مشاهدينا معنا مديره مكتب
العربيه في مصر عند ابو العزم اهلا بك
رنده وبدايه اضاءه سريعه على هذا الاجتماع
الاستثنائي في الجامعه العربيه جدول
اعماله واهم مخرجات رضا المتوقعه
صباح الخير احمد وعلى كل المشاهدين اليوم
هذا الاجتماع الاستثنائي على اجندته ثلاث
ملفات كما ذكرت ملف سوريا السودان واضيف
اليه ملف فلسطين سيبدا الاجتماع
بملف سوريا يعقبه ملف اجتماع اخر ملف
السودان ثم ملف فلسطين ثم مؤتمرا صحافيا
ربما سيعقد على ان في نحو الثالثه عصرا
بتوقيت القاهره العربيه قد حصلت على
مشاريع القرارات في كل من هذه الملفات
بشان ملف سوريا كما ذكرت وكما كان متوقعا
سيتم اقرار عوده سوريا الى مقعد الجامعه
العربيه هذا كان سوريا كانت قد
عام 2011
لم تصبح يعني لا يوجد لها مقعد في الجامعه
العربيه بسبب كل ما يجري من احداث ثم
راينا الاجتماعات التي حدثت في جده في
الرابع عشر من ابريل ثم اجتماع عمان في
ثم هذا الاجتماع الاستثنائي ولكن لن يكون
هناك تصويت بحسب ما علمنا سيكون الاقرار
باغلبيه
الموافقه وهناك اغلبيه بالفعل وافقت على
عوده سوريا الى مقعد الجامعه العربيه
لماذا هذا الاجتماع في الجامعه العربيه
لانه كما كان هناك اجراء عام 2011 لابد ان
يكون هناك اجراء مماثل الان لعوده سوريا
ولكن هذه العوده ستكون مشروطه بمعنى انه
سيكون خطوه امام خطوه انه سيكون هناك لجنه
عربيه مشكله لمراقبه ايضا تفعيل هذه
الخطوات سيكون هناك مسار سياسي مسار لحل
ازمه اللاجئين وعوده اللاجئين عوده طوعيه
ايضا ايقاف اي تهريب للمخدرات
الحفاظ على وحده سوريا اخراج الميليشيات
المسلحه حتى يتم بسط النفوذ السوري على
اراضيها ولا يكون هناك اي يعني مخاوف من
وجود اي ميليشيات مسلحه في هذا بشان سوريا
اما بشان السودان فكما نعلم هناك تثمين
على الدور السعودي الذي تقوم به المملكه
العربيه السعوديه الان باستضافه المباحثات
في جده بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع هذه المبادره السعوديه مهمه جدا
وايضا التاكيد على ان ما تم اقراره من قبل
في اجتماعات الاجتماعات الطارئه للمندوبين
بان هذه ازمه داخليه لابد ان تحل داخليا
ولا يوجد اي تدخل خارجي ولكن سيكون هناك
ايضا تاكيد على ضروره ايقاف اطلاق النار
ايقاف يعني تام ونهائي وايضا الاستمرار
العمليه السياسيه
الاقرار يعني ان يكون هناك
احتواء لكافه الفرقاء السياسيين من القوى
المدنيه الحريه والتغيير
وكل القوى التي كانت لابد ان تشارك لابد
ان تشارك في العمليه السياسيه القادمه
ولكن لابد من ايقاف تام النيران ووصول
المساعدات الانسانيه
والعمل على ربما في فيما بعد وجود قوات
مراقبه لايقاف اطلاق النيران تشارك فيها
الجامعه العربيه اما بشان فلسطين فهو
ادانه الانتهاكات الاسرائيليه في فلسطين
والتاكيد على هويه القدس الشرقيه
طيب يعني
واضح يعني
الجامعه الدول العربيه اذا تسعى لايجاد
دور كبير في حل الازمه في السودان
والنظافه هي الازمه ليس كذلك
نعم
خارجيه لان اذا كان هناك طرف خارجي سينحاز
الى احد الاطراف الداخليه ستزيد هذا من
شان الازمه وبالتالي الدور العربي مهم جدا
بما الدور الاتحاد الافريقي مهم ولكن
الدوري العربي مهم جدا وهو ما تقوم به
المملكه العربيه السعوديه في هذه المبادره
المهمه ايضا الوصول الى ايقاف نهائي
لاطلاق نيران واحد اهم الاهداف في هذا
الاجتماع
وكيفيه الوصول اليه تعلم ايضا احمد ان هذا
الاجتماع الاستثنائي بياتي قبل القمه
العربيه في الرياض المقرر لها يوم التاسع
عشر من الشهر الجاري وبالتالي حل كل هذه
المشاكل
المعلقه من المهم بمكان ان يتم اليوم قبل
غدا
هذا الاجتماع من القاهره على مديره مكتب
العربيه في مصر شكرا لك
مشاهدينا وفي تطورات النزاع في السودان
والامان المعلقه على تثبيت الهدنه ووقف
القتال تتجه الانظار ايضا الى جده التي
تشهد انطلاق مباحثات اوليه بين ممثل
القوات المسلحه السودانيه وقوات الدعم
السريع وفي محاوله لوقف الحرب المندلعه
بينهما منذ ثلاثه اسابيع والعوده الى مسار
العمليه التفاوضيه بمشاركه المدنيين على
ضوء مبادره سعوديه امريكيه وفي بيان مشترك
مشاهدينا حثة الرياض واشنطن كلا الطرفين
على الانخراط الجاد في هذه المحادثات ورسم
خريطه طريق لمباحثات لوقف العمليات
العسكريه وضمان وصول المساعده الانسانيه
للمناطق المتضرره كما رحبت الاليه
الثلاثيه التي تضم الاتحاد الافريقي
والامم المتحده وكذلك الايجاد بالمبادره
السعوديه الامريكيه ودعت الى وقف شامل
لاطلاق النار
[موسيقى]
والبرهان
انه يوقفوا الحرب دي بس
انه الخسران هو المواطن السوداني لا
خسرانه الجيش لا خسران الدعم السريع
السعوديه ونتمنى انه يحصل خير وان شاء
الله يتفقوا البلد يرجع في سلام البلد في
امان والله
احطها والناس ما شغاله اطاله يعني كده
وتزامنا مع محادثات جده بين طرفي النزاع
في السودان افاد مراس العربيه بوقوع
اشتباكات اليوم في العاصمه الخرطوم وسط
تحليق مكثف للطائرات الحربيه وسماع يدوي
قذائف ومدافع وفي اخر تطورات الميدانيه
اعلن الجيش السوداني تصدي قواته لهجوم
وقتل عدد من المهاجمين وتدمير عرباتهم
وكانت الاشتباكات ودوي المدافع بلداوي
ريفجارات تجددت في مناطق متفرقه من
الخرطوم وسط معارك في محيط القص الجمهوري
وشارع المطار وتحليق لطيران الجيش فيما
ترد قوات الدعم السلع بمضادات ارضيه
وتصاعدت اعمده الدخان في سماء الخرطوم
مشاهدينا الخرطوم معنا الصحفي عمار ابو
شيبه اهلا بك عمار وبدايه كيف بدا صباح
الخرطوم هذا اليوم نحن نتحدث عن اليوم
الثالث والعشرين منذ دراع هذه الاشتباكات
تفضل عمار
اهلا بك احمد وصباح الخير على المشاهدين
في كل مكان في هذا الصباح كانت هنالك
طلعات للطيران الحرب التابعه للقوات
المسلحه شن عدد من الطلعات الجويه ونفذ
فيها عدد من الاهداف على الارض تركزت هذه
الاهداف في محيط القصر الرئاسي وفي منطقه
شرق الخرطوم المنطقه المعروفه بالجريف
وايضا كذلك كانت مدينه بحري عدد من
الطلعات الجويه ولكن لم تسجل فيها اهدافا
على الارض رده قوات الدعم السريع بعدد من
المدافع الارضيه والمضادات الارضيه وايضا
كذلك عدد من المناوشات الخفيفه في منطقه
مطار الخرطوم كانت منذ الصباح الباكر ما
بين القوات المتواجده على الارض وكانت هذه
المناوشات لا تستمر كثيرا يعني يا احمد
ولكن الطيران الحربي كان له طلعات مكثفه
في هذا الصباح وحتى جنوبي العاصمه الخرطوم
كانت هناك طلعات للطيران الجوي ولكن تركزت
الاهداف في منطقه النيل ومنطقه محيط القصر
الرئاسي منذ صباح الباكر في هذه اللحظات
يسود الهدوء بشكل واضح وكبير لا نستمع
لتحليق الطيران الحربي او المقاتلات
الحربيه او حتى طائرات الاستطلاع ولا
نستمع لاشتباكات مواجهه مواجهه مباشره على
الارض ما بين قوات الدعم السريع والجيش
السوداني الذي ينتشر في عدد من المناطق
خاصه في محيط المطار والقصر الرئاسي
ومنطقه شرق النيل طيب عمار يعني بحاصل
متابعاتك يعني هل ما زالت قوات الدعم
السياسيه قادره على استخدام تعزيزات من
خارج الخرطوم يعني انها فقط تعتمد ربما
على وحداتها الداخليه المتواجده معها في
العاصمه
نعم بيان الجيش بالامس اكد من خلاله بان
محاولات لوصول قوات اضافيه لقوات الدعم
السريع من اجل التعزيز وان الجيش قد رصد
تلك القوات واشار الى مناطق بعينها منطقه
الزرق بالشمال دارفور وعدد من المناطق
بغربي ام درمان وعدد ايضا كذلك في مناطق
شمال كردفان وهذه المناطق تعتبر امتداد
طبيعي للدعم السريع في تلك المناطق
باعتبار ان التشوين العسكري ياتي من تلك
المناطق لعدد من المعسكرات خاصه في منطقه
الصالحه مصادر ميدانيه تحدثنا اليها
ومعلومات محليه ترد من عدد من الشهود
الذين شاهدوا عدد من السيارات التي تحمل
السلاح والمؤن لقوات الدعم السريع وهي
تتحرك وتتوجه للعاصمه الخرطوم من مناطق
عده خاصه في مناطق غرب ام درمان وولايه
شمال كردفان وهذا ربما جعل هذه المناطق
ايضا اكثر حده واكثر سخونه احيانا المعارك
خارج الولايات ولكن التركيز ايضا كذلك
يكون على المواقع الاستراتيجيه التي تنتشر
فيها قوات الدعم السريع في وسط العاصمه
الخرطوم وعدد من المناطق الطرفيه وخاصه
مدينه بحري وهنالك عدد من المواقع ايضا
العسكريه تقول قوات الدعم السريعه انها
استطاعت من خلال هذه المواقع التابعه
للجيش السوداني ان تسهم في تقديم تعزيزات
عسكريه
لقواتها هذا كله يدل على ان هذه القوات
اصبحت الان قادره على تسيير عدد من امورها
خاصه على مستوى الغذاء والسلاح وهذا واضح
من خلال ما ترد به من مضادات ارضيه
واشتباكات على الارض وما ترد فيه من خلال
المواقع التي تنتشر شكرا لك من الخرطوم
كنت معنا الصحفي عمار ابو شيبه تحياتي
عمار
في اطار متابعه الاجتماع الطارئ اليه
تراسه مصر بجامعه الدول العربيه على مستوى
وزراء الخارجيه بمقر الامان العامه
للجامعه في القاهره ويبدا بعد قليل
مشاهدين الى هذه الصور مباشره من مقر
الجامعه العربيه استعدادات للاستعدادات
انطلاق الجميع الاجتماع الاستثنائي الذي
سيدور حول ملف سوريا وايضا حول تطورات
الاخيره في السودان
ايضا مشاهدينا نذكر مره اخرى بين هذا
الاجتماع الطارئ هو ياتي على مستوى وزراء
الخارجيه العرب
وسيراس هذا الاجتماع وزير الخارجيه المصري
سامح شكري الذي تتولى بلاده حاليا الرئاسه
الدوريه لمجلس جامعه الدول العربيه مجله
المجله ايضا مشاهدينا نذكر بانها كانت
نشرت مسوده قرار وزراء خارجيه الدول
العربيه والتي تعيد مشاركه
وفوريه في اجتماعاتها وكذلك في المنظمات
التابعه قبل اجتماع وزراء الخارجيه العرب
اليوم في القاهره والاتخاذ قرار في هذا
وايضا مشاهدينا فيما يتعلق بازمه السودان
تحدثت مصادر العربيه عن تبني وزراء خارجيه
العرب لمشروع قرار يعمل على معالجه اسباب
الازمه في السودان ويؤكد مشروع القرار على
الاحترام الكامل لسياده السودان والسعي
لوقف كامل ومستدام لاطلاق النار كما يؤكد
مشروع القرار او بل القرار وزراء الخارجيه
العرب على رفض اي تدخلات خارجيه في الشان
السوداني واهميه الحفاظ على مؤسسات الدوره
في السودان وشهر مشروع قرار الى العمل على
تشكيل مجموعه اتصال للعمل على حل ازمه
السودان
ينضم الينا دكتور محمد فايز فرحات مدير
مركز الاهرام للدراسه
هل سينجح وزراء الخارج العرب في ايجاد
صيغه توافقيه حول الوضع في سوريا
والازمه في السودان ودعنا نبدا بالازمه
السودانيه
يعني فيما يتعلق بالازمه السودانيه اعتقد
ان هناك يعني فرصه كبيره للتعبير عن موقف
عربي والموقف العربي هنا القاسم المشترك
فيه هو ضروره عوده الاطراف الى مائده
المفاوضات او الحوار مره اخرى ولكن قبل
ذلك اعتقد سيكون هناك تركيز على وقف اطلاق
النار او هدنه طويله المدى نسبيا بهدف
يعني خلق اجواء مواتيه لعوده الاطراف الى
المفاوضات او على الاقل يعني وقف اطلاق
نار فبالتالي هذا القاسم المشترك في
الرؤيه العربيه اعتقد انه يمكن التوافق
عليه بسهوله لانه لا يوجد خلاف حول الحوار
بين الاطراف من حيث المبدا لا يوجد خلاف
حول مساله يعني ان تكون هناك هدنه
للاغراض انسانيه
لفتره كافيه كل هذه الامور اعتقد موضوع
توافق كبير بين المواقع بين القوى العربيه
وبالتالي ستظل هناك فرصه كبيره لخروج قرار
بهذا المضمون فضلا عن القضيه الاساسيه
المتوافق عليها ايضا وهي عدم التدخل في
الشؤون الداخليه السودانيه بمعنى عدم
تدويل الازمه فبالتالي هناك فرصه حقيقيه
للصدور قرار بهذا المعنى نحن نتحدث عن
الاسبوع الثالث من هذه المواجهات في
السودان بين الجيش والدعم السريع وهذا اول
اجتماع لجامعه الدول العربيه على مستوى
وزراء الخارجيه هل جاء تحرك الجامعه
العربيه متاخرا في تقديرك
في تقدير ليس بالضروره لان كما نعلم عقدت
ما على مستوى المندوبين وصدر قرارات يعني
كان هناك بيان مهم اسس له تعامل جامعه
الدول العربيه مع مع الازمه ومنذ الازمه
حتى الان كان هناك يعني حراك دبلوماسي
للتعامل مع الازمه سواء في اطار عربي
افريقي او في اطار دول الجوار السوداني او
في اطار دولي كل هذا يعني واخزن في
الاعتبار ان الازمه شديده التعقيد وان
هناك فجوه كبيره بين الاطراف اعتقد ان
الاجتماع اليوم هو مساله طبيعيه خاصه مع
قرب اجتماع
اجتماع يعني مجلس جامعه الدول العربيه
وبالتالي كان من الضروري ان يكون هناك
اجتماع لرفع تقرير
لجهود جامعه الدول العربيه الى مجلس
الجامعه بالتاكيد القضيه سوف تس على مساحه
كبيره من اجتماع جامعه الدول العربيه في
خلال هذا الشهر
في رايي يجب ان نميز بين مساله تعاطي
الجامعه مع الازمه وبين قدره الجامعه على
يعني مساعده الاطراف على الخروج من الازمه
الازمه بين الاطراف عميقه وفجوه الثقه
كبيره جدا وبالتالي يعني في رايي يجب الا
نحمل جامعه الدول العربيه اكثر مما يعني
يمكن ان تقوم به في ازمه شديده التعقيد
بهذا المستوى طيب فيما يتعلق بالازمه
السوريه ايضا او ملف سوريا يعني اي منصه
خارجيه الاردني قال ان وزراء الخارجيه
العرب متفقون على مساله انهاء هذه الازمه
والتوافق ايضا على
الخروجريات تصب في صلاح الازمه السوريه
بالتاكيد لكن
هو يقول ان هناك خلافات في طريقه او في
النهج الذي يمكن به حل هذه المعطله في
سوريا هل يشيل ذلك بان هناك ثمه خلافات ما
زالت حاضره بين الدول العربيه حول الملف
السوري
يعني
تطورات في الواقع يعني تشير الى ضروره
تعامل القوى العربيه وجامعه الدول العربيه
مع الملف السوري بطريقه مختلفه عما كان
عليه الوضع في عام 2011 او عام 2012 هناك
تحولات كبيره حدثت سواء فيما يتعلق بالملف
السوري نفسه على المستوى الداخلي ووضع
النظام ووضع المعارضه بشكل عام بالاضافه
الى تطورات مهمه على المستوى الاقليمي
القوى العربيه في رايي اصبح لديها مشروع
الان
لمراجعه الكثير من الملفات القائمه في
المنطقه سواء الملفات العربيه الخالصه او
فيما يتعلق بالملفات الخاصه بالعلاقه مع
قوى الجوار الاقليمي ولكن في نفس الوقت
تظل هناك بعض الخلافات الداخليه او بين
الدول العربيه فيما يتعلق بمستوى او توقيت
رجوع سوريا الى جامعه الدول العربيه
وبالتالي هذا يفتح المجال امام يعني بدائل
مختلفه لبعض يتحدث عن عوده كامله الى جمع
الدول العربيه استنادا الى عمليه ان قرار
تجميد جمع سوريه من الجامعه العربيه لا
يستند الى نص صريح فيما يتعلق بمساله
التجميد العضويه داخل ميثاق الجامعه
والبعض يتحدث عن امكانيه ان يكون هناك
عوده مشروطه لكن الثابت ان اقدم في
التطورات التي حدثت في الملف السوري او في
متعلق بمواقف القوى العربيه اتجاه الازمات
الرئيسيه في المنطقه او فيما يتعلق ايضا
بالحراك الدبلوماسي الكبير الذي يعني دار
حول الملف السوري شاهدنا يعني زيارات
لمسؤولين او وزراء خارجيه عرب لسوريا
زيارات للرئيس السوري في لدول العربيه كل
هذا يشير الى ان هناك موقفا عربيا يعني
اخذ في الطبلور في اتجاه عوده سوريا الى
جامعه الدول العربيه وهذا يعني شرط مهم
للتعامل مع قضايا الامن القومي العربي
وعلاقات الدول العربيه بدول الجوار فاعتقد
ان الاتجاه العام هو انهاء هذا الملف
بعوده سوريا الى جامعه الدول العربيه
الدكتور محمد فايز فرحات مديره مركز
الاهرام للدراسات
مشاهدينا يستمر نزوح الالاف الى مصر
وتستقبل مدينه اسوان النسبه الاكبر من
السودانيين الفارينه من العنف ويتلقون
الدعم والمساعدات في المناطق التي يلجاون
اليها
توجهنا معهم الى اسوان حيث بدات تامل
الحزين والتفكير في المستقبل واضحا على
الوجوه وفي موقف كركر في اسوان تتوقف
الحافلات البعض يستقل حافلات اخرى الى
القاهره اما الاغلبيه فسوف تستقر في اسوان
حي الصداقه المعروف منذ اعوام بانه التجمع
الاكبر لابناء الجاليه السودانيه يبدو
مقتزا بالوافدين الجدد السودانيون
المقيمون لا يتوقفون عن الحديث عما يدور
في بلادهم من اقتتال اذا زال يمشي معنا
عادي من سوء ونود
يعني انه كونه يستجيب اخواننا السودانيين
نحن واحد وفي احدى ضواحي المدينه التقينا
بمجموعه من الوافدين سودانيون من المقيمين
كانوا في انتظارهم لتوفير السكن وفرص
العمل ممن لا يملكون الاموال كلنا مع بعض
وان شاء الله رب العالمين حنقدر نوفر لاي
زور حتى فرص العمل دي هنتفق مع شباب
مصريين الحمد لله انه عارفين يا شباب كميه
من المصريين هيتفق معاهم انه اعمال ان شاء
الله بسيطه لاي سوداني ونقدر نتصرف معاه
في الحاجه دي عبد الحكم الذي تجاوز
الخمسين من العمر يسعى لعلاج زوجته
المريضه تنقصه الاموال ويبحث عن فرصه عمل
ليتمكن من علاجها انا جاي معاه عشان ادور
لشغل وان شاء الله هو عالجه عشان اقف
معاها ان شاء الله وان شاء الله وجزاكم
عند الله خير وبارك الله فيكم قصص
السودانيين القادمين لمصر قد تتشابه في
تفاصيل رحلات الهروب ولكنها تتنوع في
تفاصيل المصائر مما قد يحمله لهم قادم
الايام احمد عثمان العربيه مدينه اسوان
[موسيقى]
نشاطها مستمره مشاهدينا وفيها بعد الفاصل
قبل انسحابه الوشيك من بخموت قايدوفاج
ناري يؤكد صعوبه شني اي هجوم اخر في
المدينه
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد في تطورات
الحرب في اوكرانيا حضاره هيئه الاركان
الاوكرانيه من اخلاء روسيا لسكان بلده ان
رودار المجاوره لمحطه زابوريج النوويه
ونقلهم الى مناطق سيطره روسيا
التحذير الاوكراني سبقه تحذير مماثل من
الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه التي دعت
الى اتخاذ تدابير لضمان تشغيل المحطه بشكل
امن واشهر المدير العام لمنظمه الطاقه
الذريه الدوليه الى هذا التحذير في ضوء ما
قال انها عمليات اجلاء في بلده المجاوره
وذلك بامر من الحاكم المحلي الذي عينته
روسيا ودعا بروسيا للتحرك لمنع خطر وقوع
حادث نووي خطير على السكان والبيئه
هذا وقال مسؤولون اوكرانيون ان انظمه
الدفاع الجوي اسقط الطائرات مسيره من
بينها واحده داخل المجال الجوي العاصمه
كيف دون اصابه الانذارات في من وقوع
ما يقرب من ثلثي الاراضي الاوكرانيه في
كييف ومناطق الى الغرب منها واخرى في
الشرق وجنوبا الى منطقه خرسون وشبه جزيره
القرم وفي شبه جزيره القرم مشاهدينا
تحديدا هزه انفجارات اماكن عده بواسطه
سلسله الطائرات الاوكرانيه المسيره حيث
تمكنت انظمه الدفاع الجوي الروسيه من
اسقاط واحده على الاقل فوق ميناء دون ان
تتسبب في اصابه
وقابع الانسحاب المتوقع لقوته من باخ
متاكده رئيس مجموعه فاغنن العسكريه
الروسيه الخاصه ان القوات الروسيه تسيطر
على خمسه وتسعين في المئه من مدينه باخموت
انه لم يتلقى حتى الان اي ذخيره اضافيه من
روسيا وان وحداته بل ان وحدات
تستمر في عملياتها الى العاشر من مايو
الجريب واضاف بيريغو انه لا يمكن ان يكون
هناك هجوم بدون تدمير اسلحه العدو والتغلب
على انظمته الدفاعيه مؤكدا ان قواته تفتقر
الى الذخيره ولا يمكنها مواصله اي هجمات
اخرى
مشاهدينا ينضم الينا مواساه العربيه حذيفه
عادل اهلا بك حذيفه وكيف يبدو المشهد
الامني في العاصمه بعد الحديث عن مسيره
اقتحم السماء المدينه وايضا عن حديث عن
صفاره الانذار التي تدوي في وقت بعد اخر
نعم اهلا بك احمد في الحقيقه العاصمه كيف
الان تعيش هدوء تام وحياه طبيعيه تعلم ان
اليوم عطله هنالك طبعا حركه للمواطنين
يعني هذا الطريق الذي فيه هو طريق
يعتبر مدخل من خارج المدينه الى داخل
المدينه كما تلاحظ حركه السيارات في
الغالب هؤلاء مواطنين قضوا الاجازه خارج
المدينه في القرى الغريبه الغريبه من
العاصمه بشكل عام هنالك هدوء تم اسقاط
مسيره استطلاعيه في سماء العاصمه اكيد من
قبل طبعا اطلقت من قبل الاتحاد الروسي
كذلك كان هنالك عمليه قصف في الليله
الماضيه طالت عدد من المدن الاوكرانيه
اوديستا تعرضت لمسيرات تم اسقاطها كذلك
تعرضت لقصف في احدى المنشات الصناعيه كذلك
اكستنتين افكار وشاصه فيار طبعا كستان هذه
جبهه
قربت وهي تعتبر جبهه في الحقيقه وهي تعتبر
مركز امداد كبير جدا لجيش الاوكراني ومركز
قياده كذلك شاصا فيار ايضا تعتبر مركز
امداد للجيش الاوكراني في جبهه ضخم
والتحديدا هذا الطريق الاستراتيجي
الذي يتصف من خلاله الامدادات كذلك تعرضت
رابورسك وسليمانس كذلك تعرضتها للقصف في
الليله الماضيه بشكل عام تم صدت 50 هجوم
من قبل قوات الاتحاد الروسي في جبهه محمود
مارينكا وهي بؤره الصراع والمناطق الاكثر
الشراسه في القتال بين القوتين وكذلك 75
غاره جويه
ايضا على الصعيد الرسمي بخصوص ما اعلنه عن
امكانيه انسحابه او اسحاق قواته من
المدينه في العاشر من الشهر الحالي وكذلك
تسليمها الى القوات الشيشانيه
نعم طبعا من الجهه الاوكرانيه هم يقولون
ان هذا الامر لا يعنيهم كثيرا ايا كان من
سيكون موجودا في بخموتهم سيقاتلون وسيصدون
الهجوم في هذه الجبهه وفي هذه المدينه
ولكن طبعا مركز الدراسات الدراسات الحرب
الاوكرانيه توقع ان قوات تحاول الانسحاب
اولا للخسائر الكبيره التي تكبنتها في هذه
الجبهه على مدى تسعه اشهر هي قاتلت بشراسه
واقتحمت على الرغم من كل الظروف وقد نجحت
الخطه الاوكرانيه اوكرانيا منذ البدايه
كان دائما يتم نصحها بالانسحاب من قبل
الشركاء هي تقول انها تريد ان تحيد اكبر
قوه عسكريه للقوات الروسيه وقوات في هذه
الجبهه طالما التركيز عليها وقد نجحت في
ذلك لذلك قوات باقدر الان تحاول الانسحاب
يعني تطبيب الجنود الذين يعني اصيبوا في
هذه الجبهه وكذلك لشحن الموارد
خاصه ان هنالك مشكله امداد عسكري واما
وجود قوات القوات الشيشانيه ومساله تبديل
القوات
الشيشانيه فهذا امر كانه انسحاب خوفا من
الفشل من الصد الهجوم المضاد الاوكراني
هذا ما يراه محد دراسات الحرب اما
الاوكرانيون على الصعيد الرسمي او القوات
القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه فهي تلتزم
الصمت بهذا الصدد ولا تعلق حتى على
التبديل في هذه الجبهه بين القوات نعم
شكرا لك من كيف وانت معنا مراسل العربيه
حذيفه
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروماني ان الطائره
مقاتله الروسيه اعترضت طائره بولنديه فوق
البحر الاسود قرب الحدود البحريه
الرومانيه واكدت الوزاره ان الطائره
الهولنديه كانت تقوم بدوريه روتينيه مع
حرس الحدود الروماني لصالح الوكاله
الاوروبيه لحرس الحدود والسواحل واضافت
الدفاع الرومانيه ان هذه الطائره اعترضتها
مناورات عدوانيه وخطيره قامت بها بشكل
متكرر مقاتله 35 الروسيه معتبره ان هذه
الحادثه تعد دليلا اخر على النهج
الاستفزازي لاتحاد الروسي فوق البحر
الاسود على حد وصفها
نشاطنا مستمرا مشاهدينا وفيها بعد الفاصل
لمواجهه تهديدات
زعيم كوريا الجنوبيه واليابانيه عقدان
قيمه ثنائيه
[موسيقى]
ازمه السودان على اجنده اجتماع استثنائي
لوزراء الخارجي العرب في القاهره يبحث
ايضا عوده سوريا للجامعه
تزامنا مع مباحثات جدا لتثبيت الهدنه في
السودان تجدد الاشتباكات في خرطوم وتحليق
مكثف للمقاتلات
انفجارات متزامنه في القرم وانذارات جويه
في كييف وتحضيرات من مخاطر على محطه
قبل اسبوع من انتخابات الرئاسه التركيه
اسطنبول تتحول الى ساحه استعراض للحشود
بين اردوغان وخصمه
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد ونتوقف قليلا
مع هذه الصور المباشره لاستعدادات انطلاق
الاجتماع الطارئ الذي تتراسه مصر بجامعه
الدول العربيه على مستوى وزراء الخارجيه
بمقر الامانه العامه للجامعه العربيه في
القاهره والذي يبدا بعد قليل الاجتماع
مشاهدينا هذا الاجتماع الاستثنائي سيبحث
كما ذكرنا ازمه السودان وعبده سوريا الى
اجتماعات الجامعه العربيه
وفيما يتعلق بازمه السودان مشاهدينا تحدثت
مصادر العربيه عن تبني وزراء الخارجيه
العرب لمشروع قرار يعمل على معالجه اسباب
الازمه في السودان ويؤكد ايضا مشروع
القرار على الاحترام الكامل لسياده
السودان والسعي لوقف كامل ومستدام لاطلاق
النار كما يؤكد مشروع قرار وزراء الخارجيه
العرب على رفض اي تدخلات خارجيه في الشان
السوداني واهميه الحفاظ على مؤسسات الدوله
في السودان واشار ايضا مشروع قرار
مشاهدينا الى العمل على تشكيل مجموعه
اتصال للعمل على حل ازمه السودان
في تركيا الترقب هو سيد الموقف في السباق
الانتخابي الذي يعد الاهم في تاريخ البلاد
الحديث بعد مرور 20 عاما تقريبا وجود ضخمه
بالميادين يحاول من خلالها المرشحون
تحديدا اردوغان ومعرضه
استعراض كامل قوتهم والحصول على اكبر عدد
ممكن من الداعمين لسياسهم المختلفه في
اسطنبول مشاهدينا عقد مرشح تحالف الامه
المعارض التجمع الرئيسي بمشاركه قاده
الاحزاب الخمسه الاخرى في التحالف في
الوقت نفسه مشاهدينا يواصل اردوغان عقد
تجمعات الانتخابيه حيث هاجم المعارضه
وداعا للمنافسه اللطيفه كما سماها كما عبر
عن سعادته بالحشد الكبير في قيصر الذي
تجاوز 135 الف شخص لكن ولاول مره وفق
مراقبين يواجه اردوغان احتمال خساره حتى
في طرابزون التي من المتوقع ان يتراجع
فيها الدعم له وفق تقرير صادر عن
حيث تشير استطلاعات الراي الى ان نسبه
كبيره من الناخبين الاتراك الجدد دون سن
الخامسه والعشرين معرضون
بالمعارضون للنظام الذي ينتهجه اردوغان
نتابع
من كل حرب وصوب في اسطنبول والولايات
المجاوره تداعى انصار الطاوله السداسيه
لدعم مرشحهم كمال كالجدار اوغلو في اكبر
تجمع انتخابيا للمعارضه عشرات الالاف ضاق
بهم ميدان مالطا في الشطر الاسيوي في
اسطنبول الحق والحقوق والعداله هو لسان
حال انصار المعارضه وزعماء الطاوله
السداسيه الذين حضروا في هذا التجمع
سيذهب اكثر من 800 الف شاب في اسطنبول
يصوتون لاول مره الى صناديق الاقتراع
سنستبدل الحكومه الاستبداديه بوسائل
ديمقراطيه
المعارضه بعدتها وعديدها ارادت تحدي
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان بحجم
الحشود والتجمعات الانتخابيه فاختارت
اسطنبول للمواجهه في رساله قويه بان فرص
مرشحها بالفوز كبيره هذه المره الانتخابات
تشهد منافسه شرسه بخلاف المرات السابقه في
الاسبوع الاخير ستحسم الكثير من الاصوات
خصوصا انه يشهد نشاطا كبيرا من السياسيين
ارى ان تحالف الامه متقدم بخطوه على
التحالف
وعود انتخابيه كثيره قدمها زعماء المعارضه
للناخبين في هذا التجمع لا سيما الوعود
الاقتصاديه وتوسيع مجال الحريات وحقوق
الانسان على ما يقولون
دائما للحريات والعداله والحقوق لذلك
ساصوت له اعتقد انه سيجلب السلامه لتركيا
لدي اعاقه جسديه منذ عام 2010 طلبت حزب
العداله والتنميه مرارا بتوفير فرصه عمل
لي لكن لم يستجيبوا لطلبي هذا التجمع
الضخم للمعارضه من المنتظر ان يقابله تجمع
ضخم اخر في اسطنبول يوم الاحد لكن هذه
المره لتحالف الشعب ومرشحه الرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان في الايام الحاسمه قبل الانتخاب
ات على حجم مؤي
ديه فتح المعارضه في مواجهه اردوغان زيدان
العربيه اسطنبول
افادت وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه بان
السلطات الاسرائيليه افرجت عن النائب
الاردني عماد عدوان الذي عماد عدوان الذي
تحتجزه اسرائيل على خلفيه قضيه التهريب
تهريب المزعوم اذا دون مزيد من التفاصيل
فيما نقلت قناه المملكه الاردنيه عن محامي
النائب عماد العدوان تاكيده انتهاء توقيف
النائب بعد الغاء جلسه المحاكمه
يعقد رئيس كوريا الجنوبيه
في توثيق العلاقات بين البلدين لمواجهه
التحديدات النوويه من كوريا الشماليه
وتزايد انشطه الصين العدائيه كما يسعى
الزعيمان الى اغلاق فصل من الخلافات
التاريخيه التي هيمنه على العلاقات
اليابانيه الكوريه الجنوبيه لسنوات
تتواصل الاحتفالات في بريطانيا بمناسبه
تتويج تشارلز الثالث الماليكان ملك
بريطانيا المتوج يحضر اليوم حفلا موسيقيا
يضم مغنين مثل ليونيلشي وكاتيبيري واندريا
بوتشيلي في قلعه وينسر نتابع
[موسيقى]
توافد مئات الالاف من البريطانيين الى هذا
المكان من اجل رؤيه او لمح او حتى القاء
التحيه على الملك تشارلز والملكه كاملا
خلال المسييرتين اللتين مره من هذا الطريق
الواصل بين دير واسمينيستر وقصر بوكينغام
العائله الملكيه البريطانيه التي يعود
تاريخها الى اكثر من الف عام حافظت على
اهميتها بين البريطانيين على الاقل بين
الغالبيه المتجمعه في هذا المكان
منذ ساعات الصباح الاولى وعلى صوت ترانيم
كنيسه وستور وصلت افواج المدعوين وعلى
اطراف الطريق المؤدي للقصر اصطفى الالاف
من الناس لمشاهده مواكب الحرس الملكي تجول
العاصمه البريطانيه
بعضهم خيم هنا منذ ايام واخرون تفننوا
بملابس تزينها الاعلام البريطانيه فيما
ارتدا اخرون التيجان الملكيه وحملوا
الاعلام احتفالا
كان عليها ارتداء هذه البدله القديمه
انتظرت تتويج الملك فقط حتى اتمكن من
ارتدائها
ولم يقتصر الحضور على البريطانيين فقط
وانما جاء اخرون من مختلف دول العالم كان
من الملفت كثره الاستراليين بينهم
احضرت علم الاسترالي واشتريت التاج هذا من
المتجر وهو مثالي لهذا الجو الماطر
الاجواء العامه رائعه ولا اصدق عدد
الاشخاص الموجودين هنا
فحدث كهذا يستدعي هذا الكم من الحراسه
خاصه وانه تتويج غير مسبوق بالنسبه
للبريطانيين الذين لم تشهد الاغلبيه منهم
حفل تتويش على راس العرش البريطاني منذ 70
عاما
وحتى الامطار التي لم تتوقف منذ الصباح لم
تمنعهم من الحضور
الامطار لم تزعجنا على الاطلاق الكل يقضي
وقتا ممتعا يعيش الملك
الاستعداد لهذا الاحتفال استغرق اسابيع
ليقدموا للبريطانيين وللعالم مراسم تتويش
ابهرت كل من شاهدها من لندن عروب عبد الحق
العربيه
خطف الرجل الاميران يلي الاضواء خلال حفل
تتويج الملك
العالميه وتصدرت المشهد نسافر
بعفويه وبراءه خطف الامير لويس الاضواء
والقلوب خلال حفل تتويج جده الملك تشارلز
الثالث
لويس عمره خمس سنوات وهو نجل اميريويلز
ويليام وكيتن والرابع في ترتيب ولايه
العرش الامير الصغير لم يترك فرصه خلال
تتويج التاريخي من دون ان يضع بصمته
الخاصه وتحديدا من خلال تغيير تعابير وجهه
الملائكي حركات وردود فعل بريئه كسرت
تقاليد البروتوكول الملكي البريطاني
وارغمت والدته كيت على احتواء طفلها التي
اعتادت على تصرفاته تلك عند كل مناسبه
هامه وتاريخيه
[موسيقى]
محاسن حضاره العربيه
مشاهدينا الخلاف بين باريس وروما على
خلفيه سياسه الهجره تصدر المشهد الفرنسي
والايطالي واثار قلقا اوروبيا بعد
انتقادات حاده وجهها وزير الداخليه
الفرنسيه لرئيسه وزراء ايطاليا واتهمها
بالفشل في ملف الهجره هل ينتهي الخلاف ام
يتصاعد نتابع
هل سينتهي الخلاف بين فرنسا وايطاليا بشان
الهجره وزير الداخليه الفرنسي ازمه الهجره
في ايطاليا خطيره سببها سياسات اقصى
اليمين ايطاليا اعتبرت انتقادات الوزير
الفرنسي اهانه غير مقبوله خبراء باريس
وروما ستستعدان لغه الحوار القريبه لمصلحه
اليروما وباريس في ازمات جديده لانهما
تواجهان ازمات داخليه
فرنسا دعت الى التهدئه والحوار واشادت
بدور ايطاليا الشريك الرئيسي لباريس
الشرطه في مدينه دالاسا الامريكيه مقتل
تسعه اشخاص واصابه سبعه اخرين على الاقل
في اطلاق نار في مركز تجاري في مقاطعه
دالاس بولايه تكساس وقال رئيس شرطه
المدينه برايان هارفي ان تحقيقات الاوليه
تشير الى ان المسلحه تصرف بمفرده ولم تعرف
دوافعه بعد واضاف رئيس الشرطه ان المسلح
قتل على يد بل قتل على يد ضابط شرطه بعد
ان بدا اطلاق النار خارج مركز التسوق في
الين بولايه
قتل حوالي 12 شخصا واصيب اكثر من 30 اخرين
جراء حدث تصادم شاحنتين بعدد من السيارات
في ولايتها بحسب ما اعلن وزير الخارجيه
وفي الختام مشاهدينا بقي ان نذكر
بالعناوين
تزامنا مع مباحثات الجده لتثبيت الهدنه في
السودان تجدد الاشتباكات في الخرطوم
وتحريق المكثف للمقاتلات
انفجارات متزامنه في القرم وانذارات جويه
في كييف وتحضيرات من مخاطر على محطه
قبل اسبوع من انتخابات الرئاسه التركي
اسطنبول تتحول الى ساحه استعراض للحشود
بين اردوغان وخصمه
في امان الله مشاهدينا
[موسيقى]
قصص الانسانيه والوثائقيه والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات